super interesting new polling out of
florida that i want to talk about and
it's looking better and better for
florida governor ron desantis and it's
looking worse and worse for the former
president donald trump when we look at
florida favorability trump is way down
and desantis is doing very well and this
is relevant for a few different reasons
which we're going to talk about but top
level
when we look at the republican field for
2024 right now there's really two names
being mentioned it's donald trump and
ron desantis and of course there's all
of these other discussions about what
about republicans going back to someone
like a mitt romney who i don't think is
even remotely interested in it or
whatever else those are all perfectly
reasonable discussions or some people
saying what about don jr which i think
is idiotic but plausible given the
republican electorate or whatever else
but right now we're talking about trump
desantis and that's exactly why florida
is so important so let's take a look at
the numbers a new poll has biden losing
to desantis and trump in florida
but that's not super interesting to me
right now
uh that is that that's going to be
impacted much more by what biden does
newport this is usa today new poll says
joe biden is struggling in florida where
more than half of potential voters
disapprove of his handling of the
economy and of his job overall
suffolk university usa today network
poll of likely florida voters suggests
only 39 approve of joe biden's job 53
disapprove
um
while president trump won florida in
2020 biden and the democrats hope to
make a big play for the nation's third
most populous state one that will have
30 electoral votes in 2024 the new poll
indicates their work is cut out for them
the most important numbers here
are and i am trying to find them
uh where exactly are they
the new poll ah desantis the first term
governor leads oh no this is the florida
so let's let's actually get to the right
data
okay um
most republic many republicans see
desantis as a potential presidential
candidate in 24 but the new poll has him
losing a republican primary 4740 to
donald trump the poll has both trump and
desantis defeating biden or clinton
in a general election matchup in florida
desantis leads biden 5244
trump's margin over biden is closer
47-44 so desantis is doing better than
trump against biden in the state of
florida desantis has not publicly
disclosed a run
and of course anything could change and
it's very very early now
it's easy to write this off and say
david
this is just a florida poll this is not
a national poll
and desantis is the governor of florida
of course he's going to do well but
that's exactly why it matters because
it's florida and because florida is
likely to be so important in upcoming
elections now there's
so much still to happen
including the 2022 midterms before we
get into any even remotely
uh
specific
conversation about 2024 but there's a
very clear trend when you look at all of
the cpac straw polls that we've recently
seen
uh republican favorability polls
open-ended questions about who would you
like to see run the trends are as
follows trump favorability has been
declining
percentage of republicans who want trump
to run in 24 has been declining it's now
barely over half of republicans as we
talked about earlier this week want
trump to run in 2024
and when we talk about
who other than trump is being mentioned
the only person with any
remotely significant level of support is
ron desantis this is another reason why
i should mention
ron desantis's re-election campaign
going on right now is so important could
ron desantis lose reelection in november
and still run in 2024 successfully yes
he could
he could
but it is much more likely that
republican voters would support the guy
who won re-election in 22
than the guy who lost it uh and this
just has to do with the idea of you know
supporting a loser for some bigger
office when they lost their last
election has it happened of course it
has of course it has but this is another
reason why
if we could knock out desantis
it would make it an even bigger uphill
battle for him in 24. and the reason why
i say that
you might be saying well but david what
do you want trump no the the issue is
desantis is a less incompetent but just
as dangerous version of trump in my mind
and the fact that he's less cartoonish
but has the same disastrous political
instincts
in my mind would make him more effective
at being able to destroy the country so
i see desantis as more dangerous than
trump for that reason we're going to
continue following the numbers and we're
going to continue following the
republican civil war
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10-year warranty
you can try the mattress risk-free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video